das war richtig kaputt 19
hallo hallo ich habe meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge des étoiles ich habe die
kommentare angesehen meinte ich soll
nicht so weit rum laufen sondern lieber
seinen teil bauen und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht das mache ich heute skelette
du blödmann
so konnte ich schon dinge zu erklären
naja ich bin halt geil
also wollten alter das man alles voll
wir wollten ja das jetzt hier unten zu
bauen
ein
da sind aber krass viele monster und
kita alter und ich habe noch ein herz
fasst schaffen war nie im leben der
leute das wird richtig eng
vor allem die stapeln sicher da jetzt
alle auch weg würde tante du idiot
ja da brauchen die kühe jetzt hier nicht
auch noch ihre meinung zu sagen habe ich
nicht noch weizen ja dann können sie mal
wieder ein bisschen rum ampeln so schön
gut irgendwann möchte ich euch dann alle
abschlachten weil dann kann ich mir eine
schöne rüstung machen also erstmal
möchte ich die monster falle dort noch
richtig hinkriegen und danach können wir
uns ja dann um einen palast kümmern aber
dafür brauchen wir ja sand und da wurde
mir den tipp gegeben geht zu diesem teil
da hinten und steller fackeln hin
jetzt können wir ein mal eben machen
oder nicht ich würde sagen wir ja doch
kommt machen wir es eben ihr wollt ja
auch nicht die ganze zeit sehen dass ich
die ganze zeit nur um torkel und gar
nichts fabriziere sondern dass ich hier
auch mal ein bisschen was anderes mache
als mich die ganze zeit von monstern zu
plätten glätten zu lassen zu plätten
lassen keine ahnung
bestes deutsches ja so also das wird
jetzt ganz interessant leute das wird
jetzt echt witzig wenn wir da unten
einfach mal sonne
wir müssen uns natürlich dann schon
jetzt wenn die mitte vorarbeiten so das
ist noch wenig das war schon ein
bisschen mehr das jetzt auch schon ein
bisschen mehr
so da kommt auch noch ein bisschen sand
das ist schon sehr viel
ach das jetzt aber blöd sich dieses
instrument hier als ich meine so krass
hier brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht
wie man so lange wie dieses ding hier
einigermaßen fertig kriegen reicht das
ich kann ja auch mehrere gleichzeitig
machen flecken hier grad auf haltet euch
das mal einem inventar das geht alles
krass hoch einfach haha beste sand
maschine die es gibt
wie viel wir haben schon 46 elton ich
war die ganze zeit farben hält dank an
die leute die mir das alles sehen die
kommentare geschrieben
finde ich echt cool dass ihr mir immer
durch kommentare hilft hilft und so
weiter nicht hilft nice nice nice nice
nice
die flamme war sorge da geht noch was
hier nach er sieht das ganze teile mein
gott das ganze teil ii sieht nachher so
witzig aus
denn einfach mal so die hälfte fehlt
guckt euch das an nur sand sand sand
sand sand sand sand sand sand sand sand
okay wer mit emails viele snacks okay
was ich hoffe die torhüter von weiten
land gut das war ja witzig hälfte
einfach mal so abgetrennt aber da geht
noch mehr na ja das war es erst mal
übrigens meinten ja auch mal leute dass
da hinten das wasser das einfach nur
wenig hoch springen ist da hinten
sondern so einlade dings das heißt es
ist kein wasser sondern ganz normal von
der ladungen und ich brauche etwas zu
essen hat doch hier
da kann ich auch ein paar von stepstone
machen diese sterben da denn jetzt
gerettet hat verstehe ich nicht ich
brauche ich auch nur fenstern
so gut wir sind gewappnet ich ihr lager
noch eben die items sondern können wir
hingehen und da stellt ein bisschen was
weghauen
ach die feinde brauche ich doch die
pfeile packen damit ich immer sehr wie
viel ich noch ab jetzt geht's ab meine
lieben freunde jetzt geht's ab du jetzt
gehen wir da unten hin
hh los geht's oder da waren auch schon
direkt welche widerstände das pony da
und mittlerweile auch das wäre mal
richtig cargo ein slime hallo aber dass
das jetzt schon deutlich weniger das
merkt man schon alles tut ja super dass
ich jetzt die fackel nicht mitgenommen
habe auf jeden fall eine klasse idee
einfach so fackeln hier lassen
so wartete ich wohl jetzt mal eben und
dann können wir da auch schon eigentlich
das ganze wieder zu bauen also dann
haben wir's guckt das meine ich mit
auspacken die banken jetzt daraus
achterbahn verstehe ich nicht ich dachte
eigentlich wenn die sich aus beiden dann
kann ihr keinen schaden machen können
sie auch eigentlich nicht
der ist wahrscheinlich da so irgendwie
war da noch ein schwert kaputt
die banken sicher ist alle raus weil da
so übels viele monster drin sind es sind
als ein paar minecraft fehler also keine
fehler sondern ist es einfach weil zu
viele mops auf einem haufen sind so
wartete ich mir die fackeln
achso sense tor jetzt wird zugebaut acht
erbat sich auch ausgepackt sieht man
schon und wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
etwas spontan jedoch nicht cool
doch ist so hier ist alles ausgeleuchtet
mein gott auch ausgepackt gut also nicht
gut sondern ihnen wie naja ihr wisst was
ich meine
zum glück nicht tot das auch alles
ausgeleuchtet so waren jetzt der weg
nach unten
da war ja dann brauche ich das hier
einfach mal alles zu so damit schön
aussieht zeigt so wie du kommst wieder
weg na toll ist aber natürlich auch
keine spitzhacke mit super super planung
und wir brauchen nun ach verdammt war
wieder so klug dass das ding jetzt
gemacht haben weil wir brauchen
eigentlich gar nicht da denn das loch
sondern können das ja auch eigentlich
hier machen so dann können wir die von
hier einfach alle menschen so schräg
also wenn ihr versteht was meine
hier können wir auf zu bauen com passt
läuft super klasse also eigentlich
können wir das da oben jetzt auch
schnell wieder abbauen also nicht wieder
abbauen sondern die sachen oben
anschauen
damit bleibt ist das laut hier unten ihr
ahnt es nicht so schön wieder weg zu
sein so spitzhacke mitnehmen wo leute
jetzt jetzt knapp jetzt interessant
seine rechte als ran muss lasst mich
daran
ok alter alter alter ist das laut alter
da stürzte dabei
endlich sind runter so jetzt schauen was
da und mal ganz kurz an da werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich zehn milliarden monster
sein
sieht man schon dass es stehen ganz
hinter banken sich auch schüler welche
raus was das da ist weiß ich nicht ich
es noch kurz was sind dann würde ich
sagen kann man es dass da mal unten ganz
kurz an guckt ob gott das ist echt
extrem laute wo ich das auf easy ab sie
läuft viel zu gut die monster falle was
brauche ich dann alles noch sonst gar
nix gläubig oder fackeln brauche ich
eigentlich auch nicht so danach kann
auch die kühe mal wieder ein bisschen
was treiben hier
es juckt es liegt so die wange juckt
also ab nach unten wie husten
so habe ich mir das vorgestellt meine
mädels so weit mehr als vorgestellt vor
die ep fliegen nur so ein schwert ist
auch schon fast kaputt weil ich hier nur
monster treffen bin
roth kaputt alter und travel24 level 18
oder so so habe ich mir das vorgestellt
so habe ich mir vorstelle ok cool
das klappt ja ganz formidabel und es
wird schon wieder nacht es wird nacht
und es sind noch keine monster gespannt
gut super können wir im pendler und
danach kann man wenn es dann mal um den
tempel also man sieht auch schon dass
die monster falle funktioniert auf jeden
fall
wir brauchen aber definitiv noch mehr
sand glaube ich würd ich mal einfach so
sagen wir brauchen wir denn da für das
brauchen wir dich dich dich nämlich auch
mit einem schwert bräuchte ich eventuell
wofür ich allerdings cobblestone
benötige
wollt ihr wieder oder wat moment warte
ich kann gucken ob er wieder könnt ist
ordentlich was gewachsen
so mädels zack zack
nee du bist egal weil du hast noch
keinen partner und dann haben wir eine
kleine crew schön so also zwei schwerter
wollte ich mir noch machen und wir
brauchen fackeln für das für den ganzen
sand also ich würde sagen gelaufen jetzt
dazu ganz ganz wichtig was zu essen kann
ich auch noch mitnehmen hier so ich auch
verstehe ich warum der pumpkin nicht
wächst aber egal
also ich werde einfach jetzt sondern so
ein ganz kleines ding wirklich nur bauen
weiß auch nicht wirklich notwendig ist
nix drin gespannt aber verdingen sich
auch nicht von mehr 50
vielleicht braucht man dafür stone ich
kann es ja gleich noch mit stone
probieren also ein bisschen kopflos so
einfach verbrennen das tor gestanden
das ist so schön ruhig hier ne das ist
richtig geil ich diese ganzen kühe und
monster die ganze zeit
ich genieße das kraftvoll diese schöne
ruhe ich glaube ich jetzt wichtig
einfach mal nach draußen ich meine es
ist eher kühle temperaturen aber sonne
finde ich super geil die temperaturen
zurzeit setze ich mich da raus mach mir
den titel nicht also finden und denkt
über konnte die welt dadurch auch
letztens ein foto gesehen war es eine
facebook website vielleicht haben dass
einige von euch auch gesehen die
facebook haben
übrigens habe ich auch eine facebook
seite also darüber läuft derzeit das
gewinnspiel auch also ich glaub das
müsste schon draußen sein wenn ihr
dieses video hier gerade seht ja ist
eigentlich her müsste bayer und dort hat
jemand ein bild gepostet und meinte ja
wenn man duscht 25 minuten denkt man
über gott und die welt nach und alles
mögliche über pläne für die zukunft und
so weiter und fünf minuten wäscht man
sich wirklich
also ist es zum beispiel bei mir auch
immer wenn ich unter der dusche stehe
oder auch schon klose sind wirklich so
heißt jetzt 80 an aber sind die besten
orte um irgendwie ideen auszubrüten sage
ich mal was wenn des wortes auf dem klo
ideen ausbrüten oder ausschuss enthalten
habe ich gesagt das sind viele fackeln
hier
naja jedenfalls finde ich dass man dass
man dort wirklich auf die besten ideen
kommt zum beispiel bin ich dort doch
letztens auf die idee von einem
minecraft film gekommen der aber gerade
noch in arbeit ist
weil ich dafür zurzeit noch schauspieler
dass er schauspieler also darstellungs
personensuche sein wenn ich irgendwann
euch bei einem film brauch oder so sag
ich euch da aber auch bescheid also
macht euch da mal keine sorgen dass sein
film wird bald kommen denke ich
irgendwann vielleicht keine ahnung so
ich glaube das müsste jetzt langsam
erreichen an denen ich weiß gar nicht
wie ich dem tempel ungefähr aufbauen
will
nur wer in den sand hier ja das müsste
ein wenig reichen also hoffe ich
ich meine wir brauchen ja hauptsächlich
aus enstone cent egal ist ob das musste
reichen jeden fall ist jetzt schon der
halbe berg da oben kaputt also der das
ach so da ist er so eine sense
tonschicht dann haben wir auch einfach
nur so eine fliegende science tonschicht
das auch ganz interessant
naja also wollen wir dann hat dinge
überhaupt in bahrain
ich könnte ja mal eben wieder nach
draußen gehen und ein bisschen rum
fällen also wir sind jetzt level 24 dann
gehen wir mal nach unten